lauren's with us in richmond virginia hi
lauren welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call god bless you i love what you do
thank you love what you do how can we
help
um we are a happy happily married couple
25 years
just about to be empty nesters and we
feel like we have missed the financial
boat
so to speak we um we started out
ready to invest around 2001 when the
tech crash happened
and so we didn't invest in the stock
market and things like that because
we're
concerned we just saved up enough money
and we're getting ready to invest when
the 2008 real estate crash happened and
again we pulled back and did not invest
so we just stayed put and we just kept
saving
and now all we hear is cash is trash and
the american dollar is in trouble
and we don't we feel like we have missed
the boat and we're concerned
now that maybe we missed a way to help
us retire
how much do you have in savings
uh two million dollars
okay i'm i'm i'm absolutely amazed
and so all of this money is just money
you put in there because you've never
really made any money on your money
no we've hardly made any we have
self-ladder cds and
done some bonds but basically your rates
of return have sucked and you still put
to
got to two million dollars and and
you're still afraid
to invest yes okay but you have two
million dollars
so how did you miss the boat
how big a boat were you wanting to get
on i was gonna say that's a great one
okay but we're just we don't know now
that our kids stuff has been paid for
college and things like that we just
never took any time to do anything or
plan for us
as much as just keep our head down and
work hard and
now we picked our head up but what did
you miss
you missed out on a bunch of returns
that you could have had
four or six million instead of two
million but you still have two million
dollars so i don't think we can really
cry river here
okay but when you say four or six
million that makes me
really sad but i there's no way to fix
the power now all you can do is think
about the future
okay so okay uh let me pare it back to
you what you said to me
every time you got up the courage to
invest you
found a negative story somewhere that
caused you
to not do it fear yes
yes and now your new fear is the
american dollar is going to pot
that's your latest one yes that's your
latest one yes
and have you noticed that your other two
fears didn't come true
yes i don't like roller coasters maybe
that's the problem
yeah but the roller coaster even even
with the roller coaster
it you wouldn't have lost all your money
you would not have been broken homeless
uh that the 2008 real estate crash
actually had
almost i mean in the stock market crash
it came back and
you know it went all the way down to 6
300 and it's at 30 000
today and so you know you missed out on
all of that yeah it's a ride but
you know you're going to either uh not
have you know if you had ridden the
roller coaster
you know you might have had eight
million dollars yep
and so even if the roller coaster screws
up
it's got to really screw up to be
to en to end up with nothing you follow
yes and so i don't think that i i
personally
am not of the belief that america is
coming to an end she's got her problems
we have a whole truckload of idiots on
in both sides of the aisle
in uh dc and thank god it is not up to
them
it's up to people like you and me out
here that get actually get things done
as to how this nation runs and whether
this nation works and whether we learn
to treat each other
with some respect out here uh and so
you know this all this craziness on the
news cycle is just out of
it's just nutty everywhere so but all of
that said
i don't think that well i'm 60 i'm older
than you and i have
100 of my retirement in mutual funds
uh and a whole bunch of our wealth more
than that
in uh in real estate that i paid cash
for
because i think in both cases they are
going to go up in value dramatically
more than cds will go up
now are they going to go straight up no
they go up and they go down they go up
and they go down
and can you stand the ride so let me
give you an exercise or two okay
because here's the thing okay there's
two kinds of fear there's fear that
keeps you from touching a hot stove or
playing in traffic
because those things will get you hurt
that's good fear it protects you
the other fear is false evidence
appearing real
and that's the fear you've been
operating on and i know that because for
instance if you will pull up
just go visit with one of our
smartvestor pros and ask them to show
you
some examples don't buy anything just go
over there and start to learn
ask them to show you examples of during
these very volatile times
what did mutual fund a mutual fund be
in mutual funds c do
and follow what they did and say okay
had i invested in that
through what i feel like were very
turbulent times i don't like roller
coasters
quote here's the roller coaster ride i
would have signed up for
i think you perceive it to be the
world's tallest coaster
and you're going to go oh that's kind of
like the kitty park
when you actually look at the actual
history and the actual math
listen i don't like starting over i went
broke i don't want to start over
so i'm not investing in stuff that's
high risk either
i you know i don't i don't like extreme
volatility i don't like
high risk i don't personally invest in
any of those kinds of things
so i don't have money in bitcoin i don't
play the roulette wheel in vegas
i don't run up a bunch of debt trying to
make money i
i do very low risk stuff and so i think
you need to learn
about the historical data
on some actual real mutual funds and you
will be amazed at
how much less the risk
was than your emotions are perceiving it
and i think that'll help set you free
because here's the deal you're gonna be
fine you got two million dollars you're
gonna be fine
congratulations you're amazing that was
an amazing task that you've accomplished
but if you keep in mind this if it's
invested at ten percent rate of return
instead of one
it's going to double every seven years
so when you're 64
you're gonna have go two to four to
eight
oh and when you're 71 it's 16.
if it's at one percent it's not even
going to go up a million dollars between
now and 74.
71. so you're either gonna have 2
million or 16 million
between now and early 70s depending on
how much you're willing to
learn and if you learn to drive a car
then driving a car is not scary
but otherwise they make loud noises and
people honk
the horns on them and the t the wheels
screech and they're really scary until
you learn how to drive them
so i'm never going to learn how to drive
a car that's false evidence appearing
real